[Music]
thank you for coming down to the office
are you trying to get you on Wednesday
forever and you've been avoiding me
not avoiding me but avoiding the
conversation of coming on winners
Wednesday forever
what was the what was it what so hard
about not coming on this side well I
felt like I needed to generate some sort
of physical or some sort of achievement
yes before I could actually fund a date
you know coming on right cuz I just by
purchasing properties I felt like it I
wasn't really doing much it was just
like you know anyone could do it but to
actually turn them around and actually
getting them rented out and generating
an income yes I that was more of a more
important thing to implement the
knowledge that you've actually taught us
to make it into a successful business I
thought that would be more important
right so you wanted to just get like
nail the success yeah and then share it
yes now when we met and when you join
the Academy came to the property
investors crash course you had got some
property experience I did yeah tell me
about that well I've been a landlord for
about 20 years now talk about what you
did and stuff no tell me we did first
okay and so prior to even know you
Samuel Leeds was tell me everything so
before you I came across a Robert
Kiyosaki book accidentally I was on
holiday in another country and the only
English book that was there was Rich Dad
Poor Dad and well obviously I thought
that was just gonna be like a story book
or something but little did I know it
actually changed my life
yeah so he actually got me into property
and there was this this was in 1999 no
97 1998
think it was so nice today yeah so I
would have been like seven or eight
years old so oh when I was seven or
eight years old yeah you were reading
Robert Kiyosaki who's now one of my
mentors you were reading his book when I
was like a baby basically yeah which is
insane you do a lot thank you okay
so you read that book and then you're
like I'm gonna go into promise a yeah
over those sort of like 15 years or so
then what did you manage to achieve in
property well it went quite slowly it's
like one wouldn't after the other when
we had any extra equities in properties
we were would like finance there yes we
were by just like simple buy-to-let we
would do they'd be our bio refurbish we
finance at the time we didn't actually
know what's copy are but we thought you
know this is a good way of doing it and
I didn't value and then again that
really financed so you you would put
some money into a property and then
you'd push the value up you'd refer
there or you'd way and then yeah keep
refinancing yeah whenever there was
equity yeah yeah and how many properties
when we met did you own I had sex but
then I stopped and because section 24
came in I mean I just didn't have enough
knowledge because all the other was kind
of like accidental you know I came
across it I was like I found me really
good cheap property I did and then I had
well be the ferry increased and then I
just got that refinance and so that's
how I saw that rolled around with him
but then was section 24 the second stamp
duty everything just kind of like scared
me a bit because I didn't have enough
knowledge but going back you know a few
months well since May I came across one
of your videos okay
I know and you were like talking about
it and saying about section 24 how to
you know overcome that that sort of
thing and I was like and then I was like
wow this is like amazing
why didn't I see this before but because
I didn't have enough knowledge I
actually stopped investing
property yes I got scared
yeah and when you were making like what
that was banded with the Prophet yeah
but then what well you know one
initially when section 24 came in yeah
it was site
lots of him cuz it hadn't actually came
in don't she come in hit kicked in yet
yeah but the thing is it was kind of
scary because no one actually knew what
was going on or how it's gonna affect us
or you know how the tax was gonna be or
whether we were able to because
obviously I was refinance in them yeah
you're highly leveraged yeah I was as
you say if you can use if you can
leverage them why not you could use the
bank's money to help you make money away
then you wanted to know how to protect
yourself against 24 yeah and also as
well your property is when we met whilst
you were making a couple of ground they
were under threat with section 24 yeah
and there were single legs and you were
thinking this is very slow yeah yeah
right because I never heard of well I
never knew what hated my walls yes until
I saw in your videos right and then
after watching your videos also well
this is amazing
yeah and I was like binge watching all
your videos like like constantly but
when we met that one you ought you were
already successful but not like really
successful no well you have experience
you want to take things to a whole new
level so but not as at that level that I
wanted to be at yes yeah yes so you came
to the crash course yeah how's that that
was amazing
from well actually before the crash what
happened was certain I tried to get onto
your crash course yeah
but there were always overbooked yes
they were sold out yeah
and every time I would actually message
oh well I thought you on Facebook I
found your page I found your property
investor page on Facebook yeah I was
sorry I was like asking people whether
they had any spare tickets or I mean I
was willing to pay you extra for it yeah
but yeah luckily one
his I think his name's called soldiers
from Coventry he messaged me directly he
reached out to me and he said you
looking for a ticket I was like yeah I
was thinking AHA how much it's gonna ask
me for now but actually as I have a
spare ticket would you like it I said
well how much would you like I guess I
got it for free but I just need to go in
together we just meet out at the door
and then we're going together I'll be
fine because his sister couldn't make it
so he said he was gonna give it to me
I'll say oh my goodness like well it's
just meant to be isn't it yeah becoming
friends and what happened the crash
course then did you get with you what
you came for
yes I did well so before I attended the
crash course I knew some stuff from your
videos but I didn't have all the
knowledge so in the meantime between
learning about you and attending the
crash course i refinanced everything
that i had to release all the equity so
it was all there and I was looking I was
like phew and properties have no
properties like loads and I was I wasn't
really sure which area was going to go
into but it was around Midlands I knew
or maybe up north as you were like
saying and then I came across a property
in Leicester and I thought oh this looks
kind of good for you is it me was it
undervalue anyway it was on the market
for 147 but when it came down from quite
a few prices and because I've been
talking to the agents and stuff we had
quite a good relationship well how did
you even find these boxes and how did it
come about well well the the seller
actually lowered his price
asking price quite a bit yes how did you
come across it how did the agent they
called me directly and said that he's a
highly agent known to call you because I
kept pestering them I was like yeah I
went to quite a few feelings before we
actually came across because there was
lots and lots of properties that I
viewed yes
I've actually lost count how many
let me ask you a question yeah so
because this is really interested to me
so when you came to the crash course
what were you doing as a job um I work
for an airline actually still do and
what was they like the strongest reason
for wanting to get back into property
like you came to the crash course and
you are such a positive person like even
since the office you just bring a
presence of light wherever you go you
know you really are there you're a
really positive person
great energy and presence about you what
was it that made you think okay I've got
some properties I've kind of didn't
almost accidentally maybe not done the
best investments but still they're going
up in value it's now 15 20 years later
and now I'm desperate to get to this
crash course we financed but what was
your strongest reason for wanting to do
that I think maybe for my kids I have
three yeah really I want to leave them
like a legacy or something I want to
show them that no matter what is that
you want to do as long as you you know
you try and you learn you have the
knowledge and then you implement the
knowledge and stuff you can succeed I
want to be like a role model for them
they're my inspiration and they tell me
I'm their inspiration so no matter what
is I just want to prove to them if you
decide to do on if you decide to do
something as long as you try and go
ahead over there don't stop you
eventually use the seed so really this
company and I've generated is based well
the name is using the initials of my
three kids okay cm thank you so
hopefully this will be the start of a
legacy for them in the future
yeah so so powerful but a lot of people
are in on the academy
we are doing property because they want
to be role models to their kids yeah and
I think that's a that's a really great
way I can relate to that as a dad yeah
so okay so fast-forward and then we're
going to go through the story of how it
happened you said about you did you book
any tunes on the crash course I did how
did you remember how many books I can't
remember now because a lot of things has
happened yes
yeah cuz that's what happens on the
crash course yeah okay with that
you okay we okay so you butcher due to
the crash cause you will start calling
on some agents you decided you want to
go hard
you joined the Academy I did why'd you
join the Academy because I felt like
knowledge is the key yes
like I'm saying before and where where
when I purchased the property in
Leicester I thought that was gonna be a
good HMO but I didn't have enough
knowledge I thought well you know it's a
2-bedroom I could change into a three
bedroom or maybe a four you know
whatever but then I didn't realize there
was a task to for I never knew yeah the
knowledge is the key what do you think
of this sound you can either pay for
mistakes or pay for education yeah I
totally believe in that and I think
education is very important and how you
actually take that education and
implement it is it's also another thing
another factor yeah you I mean you can
you can go through lots of firm trouble
and lots of problems and errors but the
thing is like it'll be cheaper if you
got it right in the first place yeah for
sure
okay so after the course after joining
the Academy you've now got four
properties yeah and they're very good
properties and they're and they're
renting out now yeah and then lucrative
how much money on those four properties
are you now making per month so what I
purchased four properties and three out
of the four have been rented out and
when the final one well this the fourth
one is almost done it's on the market
now there's talks of having it or being
rented out by in an organisation okay
at for Austin price so all three all
four at the moment will generate about
3000 pounds per calendar month and
because I'm naturally doing and the
furniture leasing options to save on the
text so it's more efficient after the
three years it will generate about four
thousand pounds great so for the first
few years you ripping a monthly fee for
all of the furniture because you have to
shell up on furniture yeah but but once
that's paid for you for making four
thousand pounds is that profit that yes
yes profit per month for four houses
which is to call it the goal for Hector
motors which is to make a grand a month
per house
that's exactly why I went to HMOs yes
yeah because of the the good cash flow
I've been posting on Facebook and
Instagram and I've actually kept track
off the the BRR projects so hopefully
somewhat that would help some people
yeah because I'm trying to you know
encourage more people to go into
properties so that they have a passive
income yes I supposed to just like you
know then normal I mean you can have I
mean you can have your job yeah but I
think it's very important to have a
passive income at the same time as well
yes so you know in the unlikely event
that something happens and at least you
have something to you know secure
yourself well yeah because now you're
making two thousand pounds a month from
your previous six properties yeah you're
making three soon to be four thousand
pounds a month from your new HMOs yeah
which altogether that's a really really
good passive income yeah and you choose
to still work yeah is that because you
enjoy it or is that because is that what
you enjoy it I do I love my job
I really do I love the lifestyle of the
people I work with I think it's a
brilliant company and it's always
something that I wanted to do yeah
property resources I don't always want
to do and they've been a good mummy is
also something I've always wanted so I
feel like I'm quite blessed and I don't
know I just feel like things happen for
a reason if you look for good things
good things will happen yes so I try to
you know have that sort of mentality
really really pleased with about what
you've done is you've got previous
property experience and you know how to
be a landlord you women
you knew the basics but then you learned
HM oh yeah he's renting properties up
other rooms
yes also learned by refurbished
refinance to push those up which you
didn't accidentally in the past yes and
then you combined these two strategies
so if you like me to put you on the spot
but I'd love to have a bit of a case
study of some of the projects because
you've been I've seen the photos on
Facebook you move your heart you know
going down they've been refurbed give me
some figures give me give me the juicy
which one was the juiciest project
juiciest well I think with the one I
currently did because I actually
recorded it from the start to did you
really yeah okay so give me the one that
you documented that yeah how much did
you buy for I purchased it for hundred
twenty-six and I have yeah
so you bought it for one to six yeah and
how much money did you put down of your
own money to buy that property for one
to six
I think it's 40 yes that for that forty
grand which is from another property yes
I did yes but still to thousands you put
down and then you you've got fondant for
the rest yes there's a bridging finance
it was yes brilliant yeah you then
didn't read that Hamptons the reverb
reverb was almost 60 almost 60 so again
all in now you put about a hundred
thousand pounds in and was that did you
bridge the refurb yes I did right
brilliant perfect so if anyone who
doesn't know that means bridging man is
just a like a short term load it's not a
mortgage it's more just like you're
borrowing it for a short period of time
yeah so you've got a hundred thousand
pounds down but sixty thousand of that
is bridged
yeah so really you only put down forty
thousand of your own money yeah when she
took from another property anyway yeah
altogether the property body for one to
six you put 16 cents again that's one
six have you refinanced it yet actually
we just had the evaluation done
yesterday but we don't know what their
value minute okay what do you expect
I expect over two hundred over two
million which means that you're then
going to use all of the mortgage and
you're gonna pay if your initial costs
yeah and it'll be as little money down
deal yes as possible yeah how much do
you expect him to leave in about twenty
to thirty K hopefully hopefully
sometimes you need an exit strategy yeah
and if you end up having to these 30 or
even 40 grand yeah yeah you know okay
and it might be that you can pull out
nearly all of you yeah but it's good to
be being very you're very realistic
person it's okay so you're gonna leave
in about twenty thirty one of your own
mone yeah and then the rent
what's the total rent gonna be on that
property well gross is about two
thousand pounds on that property over
two thousand and that's where you say
after you've paid your bills your
mortgage payments you're gonna read for
about a thousand pounds yeah
what an awesome one odds hoop and
they've been in the same kind of area
yes they are
another figures sort of similar yes
great yes but this one because it's only
a four bed because a for bed isn't as
profitable as like five or six bed so
what we decide to do is to make it even
more premium we had in on Suites added
or for each of the rooms right which is
what the refit was so expensive
yeah yeah and but then we can generate a
higher rental I mean we're going to keep
it for a long periods of time
yeah so yeah so it makes sense to do it
that way how did you find hmmm
management company actually it was by
chance because I was looking at other
properties at the same time and see what
other you know opportunities there were
whether there's any more that I can
purchase yes and I came across this lady
she was so she showed me around this
certain property and she was I don't
know we just sort of clicked she was
amazing yeah and
and I said to her do you do HMOs and
then she was like yeah
and anyway we've got talking now I was
explained to me you know what exactly I
need to do and I said well I've got well
15 individual rooms that needs to be let
out
as she goes I'll do it yeah so she's
discharged ah
no percentage she takes I think it's
eight percent okay that's good it's not
bad actually
yeah no but she really is worth it she
is amazing I was promised a she's part
of my Palpatine yeah for sure yeah she
is amazing how far away do you live from
the properties actually very very close
I know you say that HMOs should be in
their bigger cities you know like good
transports and you know but I feel that
HMOs
having properties doesn't need to be in
any specific area okay as long as people
yeah you know rooms get rented out yeah
I think the thing is is just I mean I
agree I think just to speak to do your
research you know always do your
research you've done your research very
well you know you've developed some TV
images you did not buy those four
properties in a truss right well the
first one I did the first one I did
because I felt that that was a good one
now for oh that's good what I did know
about that is it you know in leicester
unless they screwed up yeah that's a
two-bedroom but you bought in a russian
screwed up but yeah ended up backfiring
oh actually in a way because I bought at
150 1000 yes
but it's how am i completed I actually
found out it's actually worth about 190
okay minimum cut so it
so the rent ability from the hateem
especially didn't work out to plan but
still yeah we do but at the same time I
also found an international school
Scholar for the university that was
employed by a university yeah so it's
actually two of them yes but they rented
out the whole house iczer one
ast yeah but
pay the top dollar what the whole year
yeah so I had like two lump sum so in a
way it was good because that love some
help me with the other projects which
make sense
I think property you or you can always
make money in property yeah but it's
just a case of the PI is big enough to
split it in different ways but the more
knowledge you have to split the pie
right you know like Prince's you found
out that was article 4 yeah went out
which is pain but because you've bought
so well and you bought it she yeah
you're what you're okay yes sir two
years later I can actually refinance
that yes all out a chunk of it out yeah
and then well I'll call that through
soon another property though no that
makes sense I mean you've done
remarkably well it was what it was an
error yeah
but then again you know as long as you
find a solution I think because you're
always gonna encounter problems and
errors and brick walls but as long as
you don't stop as long as you try to
find a solution or try to go around it I
think Eddie in a day you'll be fine
there always is a solution yeah and I
teach this on training you do finding
solutions what has it been like going
through my training programs um actually
I I loved it and I love the energy I
listen I love the atmosphere I love the
community because if there's something
that I wasn't sure off I would ask yeah
I would ask on all the groups all sorts
or even ask directly ask you guys and I
always find a answer or solution
even if it's not what I was looking for
but still it's a solution yes right and
and then we could just work around that
and Academy what was your favorite
training program favorite um I don't
know because I found that each one had
its own benefits and each one I mean the
deal sourcing that was kind of is that
DfE do setting muster class yeah you
know funny or stuff again
yeah yeah yeah that one okay
yes yes that one was very good because I
thought oh that sounds like maze think
this something that I probably would
look to do like deal sourcing in the
future maybe because I do come across a
lot of good deals yes sometimes I can't
take them all myself so it would be good
to be able to sell them on for a fee
because in the past I used to just I
used to look for something I come across
a good deal but I can't take everything
cuz you know you know money it's like
yeah my limited right exactly and so
sometimes I'm I do actually offer it to
my friends and family so this is a
really good deal if you do it you're
definitely gonna make money and I used
to just give it to them for free I
didn't realize you know I didn't realize
deal sorting was a business yes but
actually it can be quite a very
lucrative it might not be passive but
its massive yeah like that but it's good
to have like to you know you have active
income here yeah lovely through deal
sourcing all through a career yeah and
then you've got investing over here
which is passive yeah to do the two
together
yeah it's great so you mentioned at the
start of this conversation that you were
really stressed out about section 24
which is basically a new tax change okay
yeah did you find the answers you were
looking for and how to get around that
with your four previous properties after
joining the Academy yes I did
because I wasn't well actually I got it
from your videos section 24 video yes
yes so how did you get around the
problem so I opened a limited company
yes and then I just purchased properties
in that company yes yeah so basically
any any properties in the future it'll
be safeguard because obviously the the
interest system it's you can just as an
expenditure
yes if you buy through a company yeah if
you buy for a company yes would you set
up yeah I mean and after you three kids
yeah which is great so what is the plan
now what's the plan with right 20 20 20
20 because I have a few angel investors
down
at 9:00 so I'll probably be able to
maybe take on the rougher and and then
we'll probably do some flips maybe even
to convert some more HMOs I mean I would
love to do more properties so that you
know in a good good standard so that
more people have a nicer home I mean
even though it's just rooms that they're
renting out yeah it can still be classed
as a home as long as it's good yeah
because I've seen some of that seen a
very poor stay and I kind of feel bad
for those people that live in there I
mean they're not particularly cheap and
price but it's just like the qualities
and as good as you know you would hope
yeah I mean ultimately property
investing is in business yes all the
time
your house is your products yeah an
intelligent customer yeah and you want
to look after your customers do I have a
good product and it's great to see the
standard at the high standard of your
properties thank you I recommend anyone
which is to find your Facebook videos is
that they're really inspiring why do you
feel the need to try and inspire others
and share your story I mean I know he
the reason you came up with his website
you didn't want to come on but you came
on because you felt that I think I might
saying this you felt that you almost had
a duty a responsibility you've been
successful
you know we've trained you and it's been
very fruitful yeah and you felt like you
had an obligation to share that on to
inspire educate and teach others yeah
where does that passion to help other
people where does that come from I think
if it wasn't for what you offered for
example at the free crash course the
free videos and no that's nothing
I don't think I would be where I am
today I wouldn't have that knowledge I
wouldn't be able to you know progress
further I'll still be behind that brick
wall I'm trying to well just sitting
there not progressing or learning or do
anything but because of what I found
from your videos and what I learned from
your videos and from your courses I was
it sort inspired me to look further to
learn more to do more
and if it wasn't for your information I
be where I am so I'm hoping about by
sharing my my story it can help other
people and inspire them to do more
because you know if you believe you can
do it you can do it yeah so I think it's
so so true and a lot of success I think
is down to yes the information yeah
but also is down to the person and the -
implement yeah I know mindset of the
person yeah one of the things that we
try and do and I don't ever you can back
me up on this but he's out our training
programs we try and combine the even at
the crash course and on the Academy the
information but also with the
implementation and get people I don't
call it a seminar I call it a doing our
yeah it's like do it yeah yeah it's like
trying you need to get out your comfort
zone yeah quite simple I'm really shy in
front of cameras and stuff I mean I care
talking to you one-to-one but in front
of talents I am very shy my words get
tangled up as proper you know guys we do
a great job but I'm trying to get out of
that comfort zone so I'm actually
pushing myself to do record myself
talking in front of the camera and
they've posted it on on the social media
I kind of find that very difficult it's
very tough for me I am quite a shy
person naturally because what's one of
the rules on the crash course get
comfortable being uncomfortable there we
go
there's a lot of people you might be
uncovering and agents you go to that
I've seen you know one to one I'm okay
people though
the cross course you know their hands
are shaking because know what I call the
agent yeah and that's what it's like get
comfortable being on the on board you
just gotta do it
guess it easier I mean the more you do
it the easier it becomes so it's about
as the master I've actually taken action
and and not giving up because obviously
I'm here today
but it's not easy but it's getting
easier yeah yeah I also make your great
person to talk to you so you know I try
to bring the best out in people
I think property is a very
good investment Germany as well so I
think that teaching people it's quite a
safe bet
yeah because ultimately a property will
probably outlive a person and I know
even before we even met you know you
were being successful in property but
probably just leaving money on the table
no investing is smart you could have
done yeah what advice would you give to
someone that was thinking about taking
the plunge or thinking about coming down
to a property investors crash course I
think just go for it and get yourself
educated but what you're you are
educated and use that knowledge
implement it don't give up as long as
you can you know as long as you keep
going you were secede yeah I I mean I
try to encourage more people to do it
because you know it does work among
property and you've done that is passive
and you've worked hard you working
really well on your career and I think
you're gonna be a massive not will be a
massive inspiration to you yes thank you
so for property is passive though it's
now I mean if you well the initial set
up is tough but then after that is it
becomes plastic business yeah and I I
think there's two types of property
wealth creation through property it's
being a property entrepreneur deal saw
saying rent to rent that takes a lot of
work yes and then there's investing
money into property which is passive
which is how you've done it or you can
do the both together but a home coming
on the show was not as difficult it's
just like they I really appreciate
coming out thank you for having me I'm a
mad follower of you on Facebook I think
like all you post and yeah good good job
pretty proud of you